A new report in The New
York Times reveals
that Democratic Senator
Bob Menendez, his wife Nadine, hit
and killed a man
with her car in 2018
before she and the senator will married.
And this car crash is allegedly
what started the bribe
that was listed
in last month's federal indictment
against Senator Menendez his wife
and three others.
The indictment claims
that two of those co-defendants
offered to help
by name Dino Menendez a new Mercedes
in exchange
for the senator
interfering in the prosecution
of one of the co-defendants
business associates.
Nadine Menendez,
his lawyer told The New York
Times, quote,
My understanding was this individual ran
in front of her car
and she was not at fault, unquote.
Joining us now is CNN's John Miller.
John, thanks for joining us.
So according to The Times, Mrs.
Menendez was not tested
for drinking or drugs after the crash.
How unusual is it for police to not check
for that after a deadly car accident?
Well, in the state of New Jersey,
to get a test like that in a motor
vehicle accident,
even one with a fatality,
there has to be not probable cause,
but at least reasonable suspicion
observed by the officer
that the person
might be in intoxicated condition
or on drugs
that would be slurred
speech, unsteady on her feet,
smell of alcohol on the breath
and police don't observe
any of that at the scene,
according to their report.
And when you look at the video,
she is articulating the words clearly.
She appears to be steady.
So it's not something that
they could have done
absent one of those factors.
Toward video, a retired police officer
arriving on the scene
saying that his wife was friends
with Miss Menendez
and was asking
about any potential charges.
Does that raise your antenna at all?
I mean, it would raise my antenna
just because it should.
But if you listen to at least
what's recorded on tape,
I think what's more
significant is
what he's not asking what he's asking is.
He's a retired officer.
He's asking
if the prosecutor's office
is going to be involved
in Bergen County, New Jersey.
If there's a fatal accident,
the prosecutor's office
actually runs the team
along with the sheriff's department
that comes to the scene
of fatal accidents and investigates
what is not asking
is he's
not taking the officer on the side
and saying, is there anything we can do?
Can you help us out?
Is there a professional courtesy?
He's just asking
if the prosecutor's office
is going to be notified.
And he's told, yes, it is.
And he says, well, I understand why.
Indicating that they understand
that the victim has passed away.
So Richard Koop was the individual
killed in the accident
and his family has lots of questions.
Who makes the call on
whether an investigation
into a fatal car accident like this
stays open or is closed?
Well, this happens in the township of
but go to New Jersey
and their police department responds
and they immediately control the scene
But ultimately, the Bergen County
prosecutor's office
and the sheriff's
bureau criminal investigation
take over the processing of the scene
and make the determination
on criminal charges in this case.
There were no criminal charges brought.
There was no summons issued
based on the video they recovered.
And her statement,
she said,
I was driving along,
the individual darted out between cars
and the next thing I know, you know,
he was on top of my windshield.
That is roughly it.
Absent something to disprove
that, it would have been difficult
for them to bring a criminal charge.
They issued a subpoena
for her phone, though. And check.
This is important.
That means was she texting
when when she didn't see him?
Was she talking on the phone?
Was she doing something else?
And we don't have in any of these reports
the results of that subpoena.
So a couple of more questions
we have to run down.